[Music]
in the United States right now as many
people have noticed we are we are seeing
a huge escalation of our long-running
culture war unfortunately universities
are right in the heart of that so the
the right and especially right wing
media love to show video clips of
students saying outrageous things they
love to say the university is our
bastions of political correctness
they've lost their minds the left is
motivated to say no there's no not a
problem there's nothing going on it's
just that the right hates ideas they
hate universities what Greg and I do in
the book is we say no we're gonna cut
through the culture war let's just look
at what's going on let's look at what a
university should do and so when we talk
about identity politics which is a
controversial topic we start by saying
of course you need identity politics
identity politics is not a bad thing
automatically politics can be based on
any distinction it can be based on any
group interest so for gay students or
black students or women to organize
that's identity politics that's
perfectly legitimate the question is how
are they organizing what's the
overarching framework and we've seen two
versions of it in American history you
can do it the way most of the civil
rights leaders did it Martin Luther King
in particular where you draw a larger
circle around the group you emphasize
what we have in common and then you say
some of our brothers and sisters are
being denied equal access equal
opportunity or equal dignity that works
that has worked historically in much
tougher times and zones and that works
and will work on college campuses the
other way you do it which is growing on
college campuses is common enemy
identity politics it's based on the
bedouins notion me against my brother me
and my brother against our cousin me and
my brother and cousin against the
stranger it's a very general principle
of social psychology if you try to unite
people that's all unite against them
they're the bad people they are the
cause of the problems let's all stick
together that's a really dangerous thing
to do in a multi-ethnic society
especially in a university where we're
actually all trying to work together to
solve the problem we have to work on our
speech climate in the business world is
called
Speak Up culture in the academic world
it's called just basic openness to ideas
when you put people together and you
want them to talk of course people have
a lot of different goals and fears
nobody wants to say something stupid
nobody wants to say something will get
them into trouble if you can create a
really trusting environment in which
we're all in this together contribute
your ideas if someone says something you
think it's wrong say so that's going to
lead to more innovation that's going to
lead to more progress but what if what
if you have an environment in which if I
say something that offends anyone they
can report me anonymously
to HR or some other some other entity
I'm gonna think three times before I
speak up that's what we have on campus
in the bathrooms at my University there
are signs telling students how to report
me anonymously if I say anything that
offends them so I don't feel free to
speak up when I'm on campus I can speak
more openly off campus but on campus I
have to watch myself as one student said
to a friend of mine my motto is silence
is safer just shut up and you won't get
in trouble now this is a terrible speech
climate a university cannot function if
people are defensive in this way so in
universities in in organizations that
value innovation we have to not just
encourage people to speak we have to
assure them that they're not going to be
shamed humiliated or punished for
sharing an opinion in good faith look we
have a culture war raging all around us
it's very easy to take offense people
are understandably angry here within
these walls we have to put that aside we
have to trust each other we have to give
each other the benefit of the doubt and
it's going to be good for all of us to
do that